da kommt eh wieder solche kommentare
alex hat kondome schon mal gehabt
wie schlimm das nimmt mich selber echt
mit absolut was noch ganz schnell
loswerden wollte ich hatte in letzter
zeit auch probleme somit der abo box
dass ihr nicht jedes video gesehen habe
deswegen kriegt doch einfach mal neben
den abonnieren -button auf diese glocke
und dann verpasst ihr gar nicht mehr von
mir also wenn ihr da bock drauf habt
dann völlig dass auch cool also macht es
herzlich fazit video zu der anfang
machen heute 32 13 21 13 12
was glaubt netz bekommen beim ein video
ich habe heute mal wieder meine freundin
dabei
ich weiß ja selber auch keinen bock
darauf aber sie wollte unbedingt wieder
gewinne gemacht und meinen spaß
wir sind heute dazu zweit hier und heute
ich glaube das haben schon andere
youtuber in deutschland gemacht das
kommt natürlich mal wieder aus amerika
aber ein youtube deutschland findet sich
ja auch alles irgendwie dann zehn mal
wieder
und weil wir so gut zusammenpassen er
gibt zwar eigentlich gar keinen sinn
aber genau deswegen machen wir das jetzt
einfach auf und zwar ich glaube die
jungs haben das noch gar nicht gemacht
also ich zeig dir jetzt gleich produkte
von mir oder generell von jung soo
produkte und du musst halt erraten wie
teuer die wahren ich hoffe das wird mega
witzig und stellst dich richtig blöd
einmal dann hab ich was zu lachen aber
das werden wir jetzt gleich herausfinden
ich würde sagen wenn ihr bock habt dass
wir das mal umgekehrt machen also weißt
du dann musst du mir das zeigen was ja
also ich muss dann im preis von mädchen
produkten erwarten weil das kann ich
echt gut so ich habe auch sehr viele
mädchen produkte privat zu hause in
meinem bett oder so wenn ich mir zum
beispiel mal wieder die nägel macht das
einfach mal daumen nach oben da und dann
gehe ich auch mal wieder zum friseur
oder ich würde sagen bei wie vielen
tausend leicht machen wir das bei 15.000
15.000 likes umdrehen würde ich mal
sagen oder
ich habe glaube ich sechs produkte und
wir fangen erst mal an mit einer sache
ich habe zwar nur noch fifa 16 hier war
fifa 17 habe ich schon kaputt gemacht
schätze mal was kaputt ist kaputt
ob ich bin ich sauer alles
durchgebrochen wer nicht ist nicht der
rede wert auf jeden fall das ist jetzt
einfach 417 du willst es neu kaufen für
die playstation 4 wie teuer fifa 17 für
die playstation 4 vj teur 90 90 oder 40
jahre was jetzt mit 45 euro übertreffen
health sowie spielern früher schon war
nur spaß wenn man das jetzt neu auf 69
99 90 okay wir machen weiter mit meinem
persönlichen rasierschaum von gadgets
vermieter ist eine neue flasche davon
ich glaub ich schon ganz gut 5 10 euro
15 euro sagst du 15 euro und wisst ihr
schon die letzte feier 219 als wenn
jemand im zu euro für rasierschaum aus
was sollen da drin sein gold von den ja
aber das ist ja kein rasierschaum ach
ist ja rasierer sondern schaffen
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt das ich jetzt gerade glaube ich
nicht alles klappt das ja nein habe ich
nicht hier
nein ich hab das genau jetzt
ausgeblieben wir machen erstmal mit
einem anderen produkt weiter und zwar
mit
das ist geld mit dem originals
bundesliga ball von der saison ich weiß
gar nicht ob das technisch muss
überlegen nicht anfangen der
steuerschätzer wie teuer wenn man jetzt
einen neuen torfabrik auf 949 50 eur 540
euro
ganz ehrlich so wenig ja ich weiß dass
die wm bälle immer voll viel gekostet
dann biegt bundesliga will weniger
bundes bundesliga wille welle günstiger
wille also wm bälle haben immer so 60
gekostet
wenn man wenn man einen originalen
bundesliga ball kauft kostet er über 100
euro ich glaube 119 euro und wenn man
einen wm-ball kauf kostet er auch über
100 euro natürlich das sind gute bälle
gute qualität
ja mit dem kann ich hundertmal
buchhalter mit schlechten bällen und 50
mal da kannst du kannst irgendein bei
funny dass neben irgendein nein es ist
natürlich für dieses material richtig
kenne das sagt man nicht ist eine
beleidigung
mein handy bitte wieder
ich brauche es aber weil ich daher
produkte drücken geschrieben hat das ist
nicht nur gefallen was okay leute jetzt
kommen wir zu einem produkt habe ich
wirklich gedacht so kommt nimmst das
rein oder nicht aber ich finde das
gehört zur jugend dazu und das ist auch
gar kein problem das mit drei zu nehmen
deswegen eine packung gefühlsecht
directaccess echtzeit hinbekommen wieder
solche kommentare und alex hat kondome
schon mal gehabt
wie schlimm das nimmt mich jetzt aber
echt mit jetzt einfach auf kondome von
durch 3 euro 2 euro
nein ich kann nicht schätzen
6 euro 99 körper ganz so viel gesehen
ein stückchen unter okay leute wartet
das letzte woran man sich jeden fall
mein bruder in wir kommen jetzt zum
letzten produkt ich habe eigentlich die
playstation 4 nur beide controller
ausgeliehen
schöne grüße deswegen das ist ein xbox
controller und stell dir einfach vor
dass es eine playstation 4 controller
wie teuer ist ein playstation 4
controller wenn man denn jetzt im laden
kauft bei media markt saturn oder im
internet ist ungefähr gleich über ich
habe nachgeguckt 19 90 euro zwischen die
playstation 4 kostet gerade mal 199
erfolg mit einem controller sogar 90
euro weniger weniger bleibt 90 euro um
die hälfte und mir sind ungefähr passend
man wieso habe ich das gemacht hier kann
ich jetzt neu und schlagsahne ist so
richtig genau das für lass deine wut
raus ich komm lass es raus kommt herein
kommt na ja leute das was ihr im video
wir machen uns auch mal umgekehrt bald
15.000 likes und schreib doch mal
irgendwelche mädchen produkte in die
kommentare die sie dann aussuchen können
oder das doch gut
dann bleiben ihre ich mich nicht ab so
leute und wenn ihr noch nicht bescheid
wisst sie hat jetzt ein instagram
account der ist m.bahn.de ris zuviel
christine emma marie christin willst du
nicht noch paar namen dranhängen wir
sehen uns dann am dienstag wieder bayern
neuen video zeigt ihn auf jeden fall ein
19 uhr wie immer und nächsten sonntag
kommt mein lang ersehntes musikvideo
online ich habe schon gesehen und ich
bin sehr zufrieden mit
ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch ankommt
aber wie du hast auch gesehen ist gut
oder kommen sie jetzt voll gefreut in
einer stelle und wir sehen uns nächsten
sonntag